[Music]
harmonize with me
you're shining bright I'm your oyster
baby you're my Pearl
William hiya Tom here we are in the
Friendship onion studios here in
Hollywood California yes and it looks
lovely here apart from a few areas
in the walls that need to be filled with
some fanart how are we going to get
people to send for not interesting that
you've asked me that bills because we
have recently opened up the arena
the auditorium as it were if people feel
inclined to send us some fun fan art
that includes Billy and I doesn't have
to include billionaire could just be
something about the show could be
innocent anything about the French
bunion that you want to get across and
we're going to look through it at a
later date and put it up on these walls
and it will look spectacular anything
you want maybe it's Lord of the Rings
maybe it's not maybe it's sex men or
less men X-Men when you were an X-Man
remember I was just checking and we are
quite sexy man well you could put
something up at sexy men maybe you've
switched my career with Billy's career
and I am at the front of a of a
wonderful sea bearing ship with Russell
Crowe looking like I'm getting ready to
get involved in a war I don't think you
could have drove that [ __ ] that we added
no no you're exceptional amazing I took
it from the the Stars mainly but also
sometimes from the weather oh yeah I was
just feeling a little bit okay we're
heading that direction feels foreign
wow my memory I tell you what that is
incredible and you could be one of the
sexy men yeah I'd love to be a sexy I'm
hanging out with uh Hugh Jackman and
Ryan Reynolds oh huge Ackman as we used
to call him we're gonna control a
helicopter
peeling The Onion
hey what should we do some housekeeping
housekeeping
now people have sent in some stuff you
remember a couple of weeks ago we were
talking about you know if you were
watching Lord of the Rings and the
person you're watching it was was like a
big fan oh yeah and you just pretended
you'd never saw it before and you could
see sort of awkward things
yeah I'll tell you what Dave says from
Phoenix Arizona yeah he says uh here's
what I would say I would say why is
Harry Potter in Lord of the Rings and
when's he gonna use these ones
quite like that hey we've been uh
hanging out with that Elijah Wood
relatively recently and he said to us
back in the day I don't think it happens
as much now but he was consistently
confused with old Daniel Radcliffe
wasn't he and I think Daniel Radcliffe
the same yeah and one of them used to
say people forget him
guess which one would say that Harry
Potter yeah you're right yeah well
that's lovely thank you Dave and then
Carol in Swarthmore Pennsylvania I'm
gonna guess or it could be Philadelphia
PA I'm gonna say Pennsylvania it's
Pennsylvania state
yeah all right carry on thanks I think
so hi
uh accurately predict plot twists oh
yeah when Strider first says wouldn't it
be cool well when Strider first appears
thank you say wouldn't it be cool if he
turned out to be a king brilliant or
when Gandalf dies on the mountain say
wouldn't it be cool if he came back with
different colored Rose there we go so
basically spoilers all the way through
the films yeah I think that's quite good
for someone who thinks you've just
started working that's good I met a guy
recently who said that he can't watch
Lord of the Rings with his friends
anymore because he speaks out all the
lines and I said don't be that person
there are there are big chunks of films
that I know too but you have to let
people have their own experience you
know it's not really fair well I'll I'll
watch spinal tap with you once and then
you did every single thing I did well
you know the other thing to keep in mind
with me is I'm a hypocrite
Hey Stephen Stephen says here's one
about
um their siblings if you're watching it
for the first time like when you find
out Boromir and faramir are siblings you
should you should start going like oh oh
wait a minute so I'll work this out now
so is that Arwen and Galadriel are
sisters are they are they or orgando
finally they must be brothers like
Boromir and father
their brothers like barometer
yeah that'd be annoying it would be
annoying I think lots of people are just
sending in annoying things
that's basically part of it isn't it
done hey another question here from
Roger P in Fort Lauderdale Florida
said hey guys long story show I'm a
freelance photographer been doing it for
10 years and lately I've just been
feeling like I wish I was further along
or doing cooler stuff do you ever feel
that way with your acting how do you
deal with it we'd love to hear your
thoughts do do we ever feel like we were
further along or doing cooler stuff I
think yeah I think that's a human thing
yeah it's a human say everybody
everybody feels this should be
somewhere else well not everybody but
most people even if you're doing really
well and things are going good you
there's always a little bit isn't it
you're like I wish you I wish I had
those new sneakers or oh I should have a
bigger house or my car should be better
or you know what I mean
nothing is ever as perfect as you want
it to be the soul was the next thing
isn't it and I think that's the thing
with people who have a lot of money
I'm not one of them no the rock yeah I
see like the rock or or the guy that
owns Amazon or that Bezos It's never
enough is it
but it must be enough sometime they want
the Galaxy you're like there's always
the next oh I need that I need that but
actually sometimes you don't I tell you
someday I read something somewhere once
and I don't remember who said that
shocking but he said if you can sit in a
garden
like without music on not reading a book
just sit in a garden
look at the trees and and the animals
and and feel content doing that
then you that's that you have one at
life
I can do that can you though
can you yeah
and
in fact during covid when we're all
locked down in our places I took a
little blanket outside and a pillow and
a lay in front of my Garden Hill one day
and I'm going to admit this to you
because I I I don't feel any shame
around you because you and I are
interplanetarily connected are wept yeah
you're whipped I wept I said thank you
to my garden because at that point in my
particular covert experience I wasn't
seeing anyone and I've been doing a lot
of gardening putting a lot of time in
there and I was starting to see some
results and that was really the thing
getting me up in the morning and giving
me kind of targets and goals and I
openly wept I think it's a it's a huge
it's a huge lesson in lifetime if you
can be content
then that is content and grateful
you know of where you are so I would I
would say to Roger that um you know
you've just you've you've you've got
somewhere you know you're a photographer
you're working correct you're doing the
thing that you want to do so you know
you've got to try and find contentment
in that it's so important
for a moment we're here for a flash a
brief Glimpse in this universe that we
live in which is huge yeah what's the
Shakespeare all the world's a stage and
we are the floorboards that people work
on and if you go stage left it might be
a cat if you go stage right it's
probably the guy changing the curtains
from you know closing into whatever his
name was that's fine that's all right
men play many parts more sometimes it
could be a guy in a dress
sometimes it's Scooby-Doo what's up
all those roles are important and then
they're really interesting point there
and sooner or later you're dead
out out brief candle
what is this quintessent dust
tomorrow and tomorrow and tomorrow man
Delights me no
man does not Delight me what does delay
the garden no women neither our women
neither yes my God the garden delights
me I remember when you talk about being
content I remember being on a train with
you once kind of a moment we're going
maybe we're on the channel tunnel or the
tunnel as they call it over there and I
went off to uh maybe grab as a white
wine or something lovely when I came
back into the carriage I saw you from a
distance you were looking out the window
what was I wearing well I can't fully
remember I think a dress shirt no tie
you look very swish carry on we weren't
yet underground you were looking out at
you know the countryside and almost the
entire last third of your face was
covered in chocolate biscuits and he had
a wonderful contented smile on your face
and I remember stopping there for a
minute and thinking I don't know if I
want to break him out of that joy to
give him a glass of wine and then I
thought well the number one way to make
Billy even happier is to play him with
white wine especially if I've just had
half a pack of jaffica
you were almost in like a dream like a
vivid dream I could barely wait you out
of it wonderful yeah well yes I agree
with Billy on all those things just
enjoy the moment but as hard as as
harder to do than to say but it's an
it's a universal truth I was thinking
this the other day we're getting a
little uh deep into this now but I was
thinking about this the other day some
of these I mean you could mention so
many but I'm just going to mention a few
now right some of these iconic moments
in sport right or in history or history
Martin Luther King's I Have a Dream
speech
Kennedy's saying you know that's not
what you can do for your country that's
what your country can do for you it's
the other way around but you get the
idea
Michael Jordan flying through the sky
you know that was Superman
Cristiano Ronaldo doing an incredible
overhead kick what what we are
fascinated with these moments and you
can go on and on is that is someone in
the moment they're not in their past or
in their future they are vividly in
their present and because of that
they're showing up with a hundred
percent of their potential that's what
you are right now that's where we are
that's where you were with the Jaffa
Cakes looking out the window oh I know
we've nailed them nailed
we've got one more question Bill do you
want to do that one from from more Magic
on YouTube more Magic YouTube belly
since you claim to be a Michigan expert
did I claim that I think you did it yeah
if I did that I'll back it up family
there of course right do you know where
Iron Mountain Michigan is done I'd have
to say no do you know what Yoopers and
trolls are I'd have to say no so should
we revise the idea that you're a
Michigan expert if those questions
um confirm that you're an expert of
Michigan I would have to say then I I am
not let's demote you what would you be
Michigan Enthusiast that's quite good
yeah
hey Billy what I love cereal you love
cereal who doesn't love cereal the
crunch the sweetness the way you can
accidentally eat a whole box or just
sneak it as a midnight snack then you
grow up and all the adult cereals were
born and tasted Bland or get soggy
understandably we wondered if this was
the cost of growing up and eating
healthy well that is where magic spoon
comes in it's got that sweet crunchy
texture that you love from childhood but
it's healthy Dom they spent time making
sure they got it perfect that perfect
crunch the perfect taste but without
anything in there that's bad for you and
it's packed with protein dawn it's a
healthy snack just about for anyone
whether it's after a workout during the
hike midnight snack whatever it is and
there's so many flavors down there's
flavors for everyone from the richest
chocolate to the sweetest honey lovely
zero grams of sugar 13 to 14 grams of
protein and only four to five net
calories of carbs in each serving wow
low carb is keto friendly it's
gluten-free it's grain free it's soy
free and only 140 calories a serving you
can build your own box with a huge
variety of appealing flavors the
classics of course they taste just like
you remember you can mix your cocoa with
your peanut butter for a real dose of
nostalgia you've got cocoa fruity
frosted peanut butter blueberry muffin
Maple waffle honey nut cookies and cream
cinnamon roll it goes on and on and on
go to magicspoon.com onion to grab a
custom bundle of cereal and try the
magic for yourself and be sure to use
our promo code onion at checkout to save
five dollars off your order and Magic
spoon is so confident in their product
it's packed with 100 happiness guarantee
so if you don't like it for any reason
they refund your money no questions
asked remember get your next delicious
bowl of guilt-free cereal at
magicspoon.com onion and use the code
onion to save five dollars off thank you
magic spoon for sponsoring this episode
Dom yeah Reserve Bar is the online
source of premium and luxury Spirits
wine and champagne oh lovely visit
reservebar.com to create the perfect
home bar or have the ideal gift
delivered it's also where you'll find
the best the new and hard to find
bottles and those celebrity spirits that
you've been wanting to try no one does
Spirits gifting better than Reserve Bar
have a bottle custom engraved with a
name day or logo to create the perfect
gift you can build your dream home bar
at Reserve Bar just select the spirits
wine and bubbly you love they've also
got the glassware and mixing tools you
might also need Reserve Bar offers the
cocktail lounge your online source for
inspiring new cocktail recipes and the
stories behind your favorite Brands no
Dom yeah ready to drink cocktails taste
better than ever and Reserve Bar now has
them the pre-mixed drinks are great to
have on hand for outdoor events the hot
Trend in space ferrets are ready to
drink cocktails and they taste better
than ever and Reserve Bar has a huge
collection of them these canned
cocktails are great for parties when you
don't have time to attend a bar and
they're ideal for tailgating season
which is right here by the way is that
right oh yeah but it's right here right
now so visit reservebar.com today and
use promo code onion to save ten dollars
off your purchase of 75 or more on
Spirits wine or pre-made cocktails but
only when you use a special offer at
reservebar.com and the code onion that's
reservebar.com and the code onion this
offer expires December 31st 2022.
we've been lucky enough this year to be
traveling around the country in Boston I
would say it's been one of the
highlights hasn't it I absolutely loved
it Dom it's the history you see I fell
in love with America I love America
anyway the United States you mean the
United States not the Americas the
United States of America and uh I like
to I like those the sort of all the
people just trying to work out a new
country you know well Boston was was one
of the original cities in the United
States wasn't it they got to a point
where they'd been moving moving moving
and they got to a place we thought
actually this this could be a place to
play really good baseball there's a
harbor there so everything can come in
and out of there yeah so King George
sent over his people
generals people and they all went there
so they were a colony of uh England
but then England was charging them too
much taxed on
there were taxing paper
he permanent grows on trees T again in
the ground
tax in Everson and all the people of
Boston the bostonians will call them
said we've had an offer this Tyson don't
tax us so much but King George said no
no no no no no no you'll pay your taxes
taxes taxes taxes but this has something
to do with the Tea Party
Tom that's what I'm a couple of hundred
people went down to the boats where they
had tons of tea yeah from England and
they dumped them into the sea keep your
table don't want it we don't want it
we're going to pay tax on it yeah and
then it made the Bay of Boston and it
like basically a big quality yeah a
lovely big cup of tea did everyone go
swimming
you don't know where the mug and get tea
for weeks and weeks but King George sent
over a hundred ships full of a thousand
troops and he put them right in a Boston
Harbor there's ten persons of ships at
least they could be more than that
wouldn't you and uh he said nothing gets
in or out but three years wow people
were like [ __ ] so
um Washington who wasn't the president
then he was a general right General
Washington says this is [ __ ] yeah all
these ships over there we can get in or
out what are we going to do about this
so we got a young guy
His Name Escapes Me Henry something
Henry Henry anyway this young guy says
hey I know where there's some cannons
about two months away
Washington said go and get the Cannons
and he did he went two months over him
and his mates Westerly Westerly pulled
all the Cannons back over the mountains
over the river yeah Herman always mates
put them in a high hill in Boston aimed
at the British ships
and the British general get out British
general went oh
I'm in trouble that's a ship
what should I do here make always hold
the ships the king will be he'll be
annoyed yeah he'll be miffed
three three days he thought about it
and then he said
let's go over here
saw the British soldiers went back on
the boats they sealed off to England and
that's how America started have you
considered having a history show about
uh the United States because that was
very succinct it's a very good one yeah
Henry something Henry Henry John Booth
Henry no no
also at that period in history if if a
general yeah is making a decision yeah
they have to send the message which I
think could also be described as a
missive I'm sure yeah back to England
back to King George and to wait for the
reply to come back that is crazy when
you think about it right it doesn't have
time there's canons here we're in
trouble what should we do they've got a
high ground
we've only got boats
let's get over here it says
wonderful well no I feel educated well
done there's a phrase about a boat that
I very much like I'll ever hear it a
boat
is
hang on a boat
is rested in a harbor or something like
that way a boat well a boat again I
guess it's going to be good it can't be
enjoyed because I don't think a boat
enjoys anything right above oh I know
what it is oh here a boat is at home in
a harbor
but that's not where a boat is supposed
to be
we're supposed to be out on the open
door it's safe in the harbor exact boat
is safe but that's not where a boat is
supposed to be it's not what it's built
for no that's a boy is safe in the
harbor but that is not why a boat was
built lovely and that is similar to
maybe The Human Experience of course you
can be safe and well in certain places
you need to go have a look around
exactly don't point a cannon at people
though no unless you get The High Ground
hey Billy we got some voicemails should
we do those yeah let's hear one or two
well we're done hey Billy hey Dom this
is Seth from Lisbon Falls Maine
big beautiful state of Maine and I am
loving the podcast it is fantastic and
one of my favorite little segments is
where you would put a swear in The Lord
of the Rings movies
and so I would say it had to be for tree
beard
free I am no [ __ ] tree I am an ant
love you guys keep up the good work
like that little [ __ ] elves lovely
good stuff there Seth please keep
sending in places where you think uh the
Lord of the Rings trilogy deserves a
swear word
because we enjoy it we we enjoy it very
much
about another voicemail good one more
hello guys
today I went to go buy some Claude
Crystal first I bought double cream and
then after a quick Google search I
realized that double cream and clotted
cream are in fact not the same thing and
so my question for you guys is what is
your favorite type of scone to have with
clotted cream and what's your favorite
type of jam slash jelly or preserves to
put on top of that
I would love to hear your answers and
thank you all bye
we didn't catch that young lady's name
but that's okay maybe she didn't see it
should we just call her scone girl yes
the scone girl you remember back in the
day when you and I first started
traveling around uh the world and stuff
with Lord of the Rings we would fly
British Airways quite a lot and British
Airways used to serve scones with gems
delicious and a cup of tea just before
you landed the first controversial thing
the the score and girl said there was
what Jam would you put on top of it on
top of the cream Where'd you put the jam
on top of the cream or would you put the
cream on top of the jam done I mean
everybody wants to know
stuff isn't it I'm trying to think which
which would help with
um
the kind of grip inside of the scone
would it be the Jam first or the or the
cream first see I would think about that
how they mixed and also
which would be less messy for my knife
but yeah oh well that's true would you
give the knife a second thought
well I'm always thinking of single serve
gems and single serve clotted creams
because of my British Airways experience
I don't think I've had a scone with
clotted cream and jam outside of a
British Airways plane you've lived a
life I like a scone with the raisins and
currants and sultanas and stuff I like I
like them playing yeah no fruit I like
them hot I like them toasted slightly
over toasted a little crunchy dark brown
I put the cream on first then the jam I
don't double it up because then you're
only getting one one go at this going
I'll take I'll eat the bottom bit first
no so you're just having but you're just
having scone and cream scone cream and
jam
ah you put oh on the one thing
that's gone I've still got the tops gun
I actually like that method because now
like you said you got two girls it's
almost like getting two scones yeah and
plus it's a nice height for your mouth I
don't have a big mouse though no you
don't so I feel scone if it's risen well
would like would be quite difficult for
my mouth yeah so I get the bottom
and then the top cream Jam little break
in between oh Yellow Brick like a minute
or two couple of minutes just a maybe a
couple of drunks of coffee a little cup
of tea tea tea I think tea with a c with
a score in the united you don't want
something too overbearing in its flame
you know and I'd have maybe five or six
mouthfuls of tea before the Tilt but
would then go down lovely I'm gonna I'm
actually gonna steal that method from
now on because like you said you're
getting double the scone half the height
yeah that's right have you ever come
across people in the world that say
height height no never I have no I'm
telling you if there's anyone out there
that says the word height
in this way height
please get in touch and explain why
there are people that do that but
there's not a t there's not a th at the
end there's a GH before hi is there
anything that I say where anytime I say
it you always go
that annoys me is it when I say I love
you Billy and my mate you go I make my
blood nothing you do annoys me really
yeah that means that I can't say the
thing
you've canceled it it wasn't a thing
it's not a Checkmate but it's certainly
a check it's whether you want to play
through that check now there's nothing
about it no come on no no it genuinely
doesn't annoy me
but we do say the word licorice
different don't we yeah I say Licorice
and Ukraine you say licris no as as a
three-syllable word for me we'll go on
let go rest licorice licorice is that a
Scottish thing don't know I wonder any
slippery let me know if uh if you're
saying licorice what's your favorite
liquor is also
I think I like the triple sandwich wrong
what's yours
um the circular one pink no no no no too
much coconut the double One Brown no
that's coffee isn't it yeah no no the
little circle with all the hundreds and
thousands no I'll agree with you on that
that's my wife's favorite and my sons
and also not licorice there's nothing in
that there's licorice are you sure the
the channel is it the jelly pasta yeah
no it's licorice
I'm gonna poo poo that anyone who's a uh
licorice also expert please get in touch
or maybe bassets
who make our relation Enthusiast yeah
maybe you're an Enthusiast I love lacros
salsa would you say that's your favorite
British sweetie yeah
which I think about mine is
Bon bonds no I think maybe call the
cubes I know I think maybe yes you know
I like jelly stuff a sports mixture
because if you get wine gums minted Gems
or something else the black is a kind of
frothy kind of almost licoricey taste
and I don't like it I said why not like
oh I don't like it oh oh it's not Sports
mixture it's fruit fruit salad
but in a fruit salad the black is a
black currant and I love black currant
which brings me back onto the scone or
scone uh I like a sharp gem
oh do you well give us your jam I would
say either black currant or red currant
Jam I like a jam that makes you go oh I
would just always go strawberry just as
a sort of
it's just you know it's going to be good
yeah but it's a bit boring I know what
you mean yeah yeah like there's a
there's been occasions when I've had a
grape jam and I thought that's nice that
and I think the difference the
distinction because it was in the
voicemail the difference between a jam
and a jelly is that a jelly is simply
that jelly kind of consistency whereas a
gem contains fruit
is that true I think that is true and
you know sometimes I will make up
stories but I think I've got it right
there if there are any GM or jelly
experts that want to come on the show
and give us an education we'd love to
have you William what Tiffany's here
come on you read out can we read out a
little thing left yeah hello Tiffany
Tiffany that's Billy to your right and
then a little further over it's me I'm
the one that's gonna do the talking now
okay but you don't need to look at me
but you can I'm gonna look at you and
make it awkward oh this is weird already
I read this blurb as fast as I can
Tiffany Smith is the definition of the
modern day Hollywood multi-hyphen do you
now feel a bit weird Tiffany yeah I do
feel weird yeah as a popular host up and
coming actress and in demand web
personality as an actress she showcased
her beauty and talent as a spot on
Meghan Markle in lifetimes Harry and
Megan becoming Royal and has been
featured on TV shows such as
Supernatural NCIS Los Angeles the CW's
Jane the Virgin [ __ ] his bad Enemy
Lines directed by MC G and films like
Sony Pictures House of demons Tiffany
has additionally lent her voice chops as
the voice of Hawk Girl Hawk Hawk Girl in
Legos
thank you okay supervillains video game
acting and hosting aside Tiffany is an
avid supporter of environmental and
ocean conservation see she has curated
Partnerships with companies that support
the cause such as Earth's oceans and
lonely whale shows to support such
organizations as Operation Smile UNICEF
and operation gratitude Tiffany spends
much of her free time learning
we're almost at the end Tiffany spends
much of her time writing up her bio and
also learning stunt work perfecting her
aim at the firing range checking out
local vintage car shows sweating it out
in hot yoga scuba diving we scuba dive
too and putting her newly acquired
motorcycle license to good use Tiffany's
welcome to the show hello there's a lot
that was so uncomfortable for me yeah I
got I started out uncomfortable and then
became comfortable and you started out
comfortable but I think I'm like
sweating now yeah I am sweat Dom I hate
to say this because this isn't part of
the show my stomach is killing me from
that I think it from that hot pepper I'm
gonna have to walk for a second are you
gonna go walk yourself are you getting
cramps yeah William you said you mate is
the bathroom nearby here like please
hear what's going on sweating
don't worry Billy go walk around I'll
make Tiffany at home well Tiffany let's
talk about a few things that you and I
both enjoy it's a great way to start her
show I just made one of the host sleeves
yeah he's just like I'm out of here I
can't do it let's talk about scuba
diving yeah how long have you been scuba
diving what made you want to learn
um so I've been scuba diving probably
for like four or five years now
um and I speedily went through like the
written part of the scuba diving stuff
because I was going on a trip with some
friends and we had the opportunity to
dive the Blue Hole which like amazing
you're not supposed to do it
right right very deep yeah it's really
really deep
um but we did our like open water in the
ocean and everything was fine the guy
that was training us was like if you
guys can get through this like we'll
keep pushing you on the trip and then
hopefully we'll be able to get to the
blue hole right and we did and it was
amazing and like
and I've done shipwreck Dives and it's
like it feels really meditative yeah
you're in a brand new world aren't you
it's a wonderful thing it's very I mean
not only is it taking you away from
your phone and everything that's going
on above land but it's one of those
things all the things that I do in my
life that I'm like consistently
trying to do over and over again forces
you into the moment and scuba diving is
all about the moment because you have to
be conscious of like where you are in
space and being safe and what's your air
saying and you know where's your crew
and all that kind of stuff yep yeah I
love it as well it's super fun yeah
one of the scariest was we went diving
to see
um
what are they called Shoot
on the on the bottom of the ocean the
eels no manta rays oh manta rays but it
was a night Dive Right and my flashlight
broke and that was like being in the
moment I was like I literally grabbed
one of my friends I was diving with
because I was like it was Pitch Black I
was like I don't know what's what's up
and what's down anymore
um but it's still one of my favorite
things to do yeah it's super duper fun I
learned with Billy did you the man who
just walked out because oh I don't know
who that person is
we learn in New Zealand so we
I think we had moved in actually I think
it was when we were shooting the second
film and they had gone into heavy
production on a sequence called Helms
Deep which which doesn't include us
and we were probably a week away from
starting to do stuff uh with tree beard
and they kind of said to us look you'll
be working but this is going to be a
pretty kind of you know easy week for
you so Billy and I were like what are we
gonna do and we said let's learn to
scuba dub so did you tell did you tell
production you guys were learning to
scuba dive I think they probably had to
but I don't know I'm surprised they let
you yeah because they weren't over the
moon about us surfing yeah but we did it
anyway uh and I think they got they got
okay with us surfing and then Vigo came
out with us one day and uh got a black
eye surfing
so Vigo never surf with us again but I
think we were young to remain just they
just let us kind of you probably didn't
tell them
Orlando Orlando and I did like the
world's biggest bungee jump we didn't
tell them about that yeah yeah actually
Ian McAllen did that with us oh my gosh
which is impressive that's very cool
um yeah and then I so we did the world's
biggest bungee jump which at the time
this is aging me but it's fine it was
recorded onto a VHS tape
and I took that home to show my mom and
dad and my dad very kindly recorded the
football over it for me yeah so I went
out to the pub with my friends and I
came back and my dad said hey I know you
missed matching the day because you're
at the pub so I recorded it and I had
this sinking feeling you're like on the
tape did you take the tape out before
you curled it he went no way I said
that's my bungee jump my dad was like
sorry about that could you go back to
them and get another copy don't think it
really works like that in VHS
don't they have I mean I don't think
they kept it I mean you're just like
another grunt showing up so like there
you go here's your tank get out I mean I
I did
um skydiving but that that was all
digital so right no one could record
over them when you when did you go
skydiving that was like I want to say
like four or five years ago I did like a
New Year's trip with friends on a boat
and at the end of the trip my friend was
like I'm gonna go skydiving tomorrow you
want to come I was like yes I do I've
never done it before
um and I just remember we were about to
go up and they put us in this tiny plane
and I as we're going up I'm like I can
see through the floor of this plane
right right so I was like is this safe
exactly and I was like well I'm gonna be
jumping on the plane anyway so does it
really matter you've got a parachute
under that point so first comes to the
worst you just say what what am I
supposed to pull exactly and that wasn't
all also an incredible experience and I
would love to do it again would you do
here's William would you describe
yourself as a rather impulsive creature
Tiffany
I like I like Adventure I like trying
new things now I will not be trying that
pepper though because I don't want to
have to run away talk us through your
symptoms
that was awful what's happening I I well
the guy who made the paper
said that we could get cramps like later
yeah like menstrual cramps I've never
had that
but really yeah he honestly said he did
describe his menstrual and while we were
talking there my stomach was like
cramping up and I started sweating that
was going to pass out or something I
mean that's just a taste of being a
woman I guess literally just eat a piece
of pepper and yeah it's difficult being
a woman have you seen those videos there
I forget um it's like the try guys where
they put the electric shocks on
themselves and it like goes up to the
point of like what cramps would be like
they're like oh God yeah like I never
get stomach cramps I don't but that was
what I thought I was going to spew up I
thought I was going to be sick no I
looked over at you and underneath your
eyes you were sweating and your forehead
and I thought easier I thought I was
going to pass out in front of you and
that would have been embarrassing well
I'm glad it just I I thought it was
gonna come out the other end
well at some point I mean that's like me
isn't that sorry we don't know each
other that well but I'm totally
comfortable talking about poop
that's just that's biology isn't it yeah
but I've never felt like that and I
really I haven't eaten much today Dom so
I think I think if I'd eaten something I
think I would have been sick well I'm
glad you're back and you don't look
sweaty I feel I honestly it's like have
you ever like lost your purse
yeah and then and where is this going
and then you you're like oh my God
that's awful it's got all my credit
cards and my money and everything and
then when you find it
it makes you so happy it's almost worth
losing it
that's how I feel now I feel good I
wanna I wanna support you and say yes I
know how that feels have you never have
you never done that no really I mean
okay I could say losing yes losing
something and then finding it being like
yes but then I kind of go to the place
where I'm like why did I put it there in
the first place oh you see you've been
hard on yourself just enjoy the Euphoria
as I am he loses stuff all the time I'm
saying this to Elijah uh when we were
when we recently took a trip we were
talking about how many pairs of
sunglasses and spectacles you've lost
over the years but I said to Elijah to
give Billy his credit he doesn't really
care yeah he's like yeah do you buy
cheap ones though and lose them or do
you buy like spendy ones and then now
here's the thing uh buy cheap ones
especially for reading because you you
won't be at this yet Tiffany but as you
as you get older as I have done just
through you know
yeah just like being born early been
born earlier uh I can't read as good as
I used to yeah and um so I've slowly
degenerated uh and I get these like
terrible glasses not these ones but I
get these terrible ones for like fifteen
dollars from the drugstore exactly yeah
and you lose those and the legs fall off
and you don't care but then the legs
yeah these the arms is the arms I would
think so what would you call it I mean I
understood what you were saying when you
said legs but I do think most people say
right
and then
oh yeah so I started buying like these
these are about there no I'm just
envisioning glasses with arms or with
legs on them and I'm like legs just
immediately get very often yeah I think
legs are better and then you keep them
open you shut them
in this area and uh but no I spend a bit
more so that I'll try not to lose
something I still do lose them I
probably got 20 pairs of reading glasses
in the house scattered
because you just that that stresses me
out thinking about that you just have 20
things just like you don't know randomly
trying to get excited when you find
things exactly imagine how exciting it
is do you do it on purpose just so you
can be excited when you find it I don't
know
Billy can I ask you a question yeah go
hunter will you be honest with me yeah
do you secretly want me to be having
cramps as well are you are you a bit
disappointed that I because Billy and I
ate Peppers at the same time and then we
had a little bit of competitiveness
where I was like I think I can handle it
better than you and Billy's like well I
ate more than you and I was like well
that's not an exact science but are you
hoping that I get I think what happened
as I mentioned as you come in Tiffany is
I ate it down to the seeds but he just
scraped the skin not true he never had
any seeds
I don't have seeds I highly doubt you I
will show you it sure I mean there are
cameras in here so there's probably
evidence there's evidence wow I am
crampless can we please talk about
Tiffany and stop talking about you carry
on wait I have to ask a question so we
didn't you were like describing stuff
from Lord of the Rings and I'm just
gonna be like I'm a huge Lord of the
Rings fan I grew up reading the books oh
great I have an Elvish tattoo so you
don't need to oh wow this section called
Helms Deep I'm like yeah I know yeah I
just always try and be like conscious of
the fact yeah you know we do have people
that probably don't know those things
and you don't big kind of yeah an ego
not be like well you know we're making
those movies yeah sorry what movies so
oh well cool
Tiffany is a well-known geek I know that
and what what does the LV say well I
think that it says light and dark places
but I don't I translated it online so it
could say like yeah
let's have a look at it come on Billy
Billy speaks fluent Elvis can you read
would you be able to read it
that's exactly what it says okay well
done you're like Galadriel sorry I mean
I I'd like to think of myself a little
bit that way good like uh Melvin
princess just more like reminder for
myself to be a light all the time when I
can good I like that we like the thing
yeah we that's what we're about you know
there's a there's a it's it's kind of
easy isn't it to be negative and cynical
yeah it's easier yeah and especially in
art as well
you know it's it's kind of easier it's
harder to try and be light and trying to
be positive so good on you I also think
it's a strange thing with being positive
where I think sometimes positivity can
be misconstrued as like glibness or like
a like a lightness about you whether
it's no depth yeah you're just like oh
that person's generally happy generally
fine about stuff generally okay but it's
a choice positivity you are actively
choosing I have it a lot where someone
comes over to me and says oh this and
that this and that and I go oh okay well
what about this there's that's a great
thing to look at in that regard you know
I do these q and A's on Instagram every
so often and very often people will say
I don't know what to do with my life and
I'll write back and say what an amazing
position you're in like there's all that
potential for you to choose you've not
gone down a route and now you have to
backtrack you basically have every
single opportunity open to you and it's
just a way of looking at life you know
it's just finding ways to celebrate
things yeah because it's like no matter
what like there was a I had to call my
friend the other day because there was a
job that I wanted and didn't end up
getting it and I was like okay what's
wrong with my mindset do I need to tweak
something and she's like no you need to
think about it in the way that that had
to go away for the right thing for you
to show up so she's like celebrate that
it's gone be joyful about it and so it's
like you have it is consistently a
choice that you make to say I'm gonna
look for the Silver Lining I'm gonna
find the reason why I can celebrate this
thing can I tell you a little quick
story about it yeah please do as you
like the Lord of the Rings because
you've got Elven tattoos and I loved the
musical Rent
you know the rent yeah and it was coming
to London and I auditioned for it and uh
I I auditioned for it for like nine
times or something
and it was getting so close to like me
doing it and to the point that I was
doing a play at the time and my agent
came up and says you got Wren and I was
like oh great so the next day I'm like
telling everyone and then she said oh no
wait the rethinking it and I didn't get
it
who tells your agent that you got it I
know the casting director well it's and
a sort of you know don't say anything
but obviously he's got it
so I was I was devastated but like two
weeks later I auditioned for Lord of the
Rings and if I'd got rent I wouldn't
have auditioned for Lord of the Rings
because I'd have been doing rent yeah or
no one that I was about to do right yeah
so it's your friends absolutely right
sometimes yeah things have to move out
the way so it leaves the space for the
other thing someone told me this analogy
one time where they were like when you
look at a tapestry the front of it looks
so well put together but if you look at
the back side it's like what in the
world is going on right and when you're
in it in your own life it feels like
you're only looking at the back side
until you can get some perspective and
then you see the other side of it it's
like this beautiful thing then that's
all perfectly come together crochet is
like that isn't it cross stitch exactly
the one that goes um yeah there's a
little crusted 500 yeah
155
000 minutes just like that that's how
many minutes there are in this play no
no it's not it's not now a bunch of
people no legs they like have clocks and
they're all famous you take to get to
the diner today how long did you take to
get to down the stairs six thousand
twenty five thousand three thousand
minutes that's the iconic it's pretty
much nailed it yeah was that how did you
start in in this business yeah let's
take it back what was your first
artistic when you what were you doing
no I thought I was gonna be a pop singer
oh who who would you have modeled
yourself on
um well at the time I wanted to be like
spice the Spice Girls
who's your favorite spicy girl we met
the spices
scary well but yeah what who would I
have been who's your favorite no who was
your favorite
I just thought that she had the most
amount of genuine Pizzazz about it what
about you can I guess yeah baby
that's what I would say yeah what was it
and we met Baby Spice didn't we we
actually were we had to do a TV show
Once
I remember yeah yeah she was lovely were
you nervous I was nervous yeah how'd
that go yeah it went good it was a good
scene and uh but I didn't tell her I had
to cry Emma Bunton the weirdest thing
about working in this industry and being
in this industry when you meet people
and you're like I had a crush on like I
still go back to the Jason Momoa and
Lisa Benet thing that it was like he put
out that he had a crush on her when he
was young very cool it's always so
bizarre to me yeah I had a crush on
Kylie Minogue that never transpired
there's still time yeah I think she's
married now or pretty much oh wow I also
like professional crushes have you had
those which is not a I would like to
give you a special kiss in the dark time
uh Crush it's more of I admire you so
much that I'm crushing on you yes very
lucky to meet David Bowie and I when I
was spent time in his presence I was
just like like I think I'm in love with
you and yeah it's just you said that
yeah no I thought I wish you did you
probably would have loved that deep deep
admiration for someone who showed up
just as a very friendly cool kind of guy
and obviously he knew about Lord of the
Rings I think he auditioned for elrond
and you know it didn't quite work out
type thing but I was just in awe of the
men and his talent I'm so addicted to
Talent you know but let's go back to you
so you wanted to be a pop star you
wanted to be the sixth spice yeah I
thought it was a new hip-hop singer
um I grew up out in California and my
sister auditioned for stuff when she was
younger but she booked commercials and
then she would think
she had to go out every time the
commercial aired so she thought she had
to leave the family every time there was
her commercial on TV so she didn't want
to audition anymore she's my older
sister so my parents were like you're
not gonna audition we'll wait and see
when you get older if you still want to
be in the industry
um and so I started taking voice lessons
and I was like this is what I want to do
and both my parents were like you're
going to college I was like cool okay
good
um what did you study at College I
studied broadcast journalism and then I
minored in music industry because I was
like I'll be able to write my own
contracts
that was a thought in my head I was like
one job is kind of entertainmenting but
I could write somewhere it's like a
little less scary than acting or singing
um and then I just I grew up reading
comic books and playing video games and
all that kind of geek stuff and G4 was
out around the time when I was
graduating and I was like I want to be
on that show I want to like be able to
talk to people I just I think because I
moved so much I really enjoyed talking
to people and getting to know them and
asking questions and kind of got to this
place where you're like no matter who
the person is you're going gonna have
something in common you're going to find
some common ground
so that kind of led into hosting and
people started finding out oh she really
knows her stuff she really does go to a
comic shop she really does like this
stuff
um and it just kind of LED one job to
another to another to another and then
um the acting stuff started happening
because I I don't the only way I can
describe it is that like I think in
every other industry you can get a
promotion you can move up you can try
new things and for me for hosting it's
like
not that I've done everything in the
world as a host but it's like I could I
feel really confident in it it comes
pretty naturally to me at this point
that I'm like I would watch people on
set and I was like but I want to
challenge myself a bit it's like where
you're asking are you impulsive are you
I just like challenging myself and
trying new things all the time and
now with acting it feels like every part
of me is awake when I'm there in a
different way than it is for anything
else for me so that's kind of the
trajectory transition yeah the singing
stuff I did for a little while and the
first group that I was a part of they
recorded two of us
what was it called the group it was well
we never put anything out we were in a
development deal we were called impulse
impulsiveness so they recorded two of us
had other girls come into the studio
didn't record them and then I was like I
don't one that's a lie that I don't want
to have going on with this group of
women anyway and then they were like
also we want you to say that you're 17.
and I was like no I'm done really how
old were you uh I must have been 21. oh
that's true oh wow um well weird thing
to ask yeah so I was just like there's
enough weird stuff in this industry
anyway that I was like I don't want to
start it on all these lies like this is
that's not who I am so you know then the
hosting stuff happened I was like I can
totally be myself and be a dork and
that's great do you know I watched
Greece last night because of the
untimely death of the wonderful Olivia
Newton John yeah and Greece is probably
in the top three
musicals of all time but there are some
incredibly out of date inappropriate
things that go on in Greece like I mean
not only did do all the cast look kind
of 35 in the supposed to be school kids
but there's some objectifying women
which is really inappropriate there's a
lot of language that is not cool and
then there's some like you know like
Rizzo it has like a pregnancy scare and
basically the entire group are like well
you're done yeah you're just done you're
not part of our group anymore and then
when she finds out that she's not
pregnant they're like oh you're back in
the gang yeah oh wow also Vince Fontaine
you know the guy who runs the whole
dancer he essentially tries to drug
Marty he tries to kind of roof here and
she's a school girl and he's like a 50
year old TV star I was watching last
night I mean it's a it's a brilliant
film the music in it is extraordinary
but I was like this is not aged well at
all that's a lot of old movies though
like I just rewatched the original Top
Gun and I was like there's stuff in
there where it's like Tom Cruise's
character follows her into the bathroom
yeah yeah yeah yeah it's just like the
same you kind of have to look at stuff
and be like oh is it different time like
I watched Swiss Family Robinson and I
was like oh dear no no you can't watch
that yeah yeah we were saying on a
podcast at some point the if you watch
the original Tom crew uh Tom Cruise if
you watch the original Top Gun yeah with
a view of Tom Cruise's character kind of
being a bit of a jackass he just is yeah
he almost gets goose-fired like three or
four times he's horrible to everyone
he's extremely dangerous yeah he's mean
to his office to his commanding officers
and to the girl that he's supposed to be
in love then he smiles and then he's
gone because on those Wayfarers hello
it's true I saw a stand-up talking about
Tom Cruise movies yeah and he says
basically you know he's a guy who makes
cocktails really well
and then he loses the kind of his
confidence in making cocktails and then
he meets a woman a beautiful woman who
teaches them again they can make
cocktails really good or he drives a car
really good but then he loses the
confidence and driving a camera woman
meets a really beautiful woman who gave
them a comment yeah he also runs really
well oh he's a good runner oh he's a
great Runner he's a great Runner so have
you
watch the Top Gun yeah I've seen it
twice I loved it I loved it I I I I I
can't tell you how much I loved it try
it was a zeph have you ever lost your
wallet
it was like um
I could tell every beat they were
wanting me to feel and every emotion but
I didn't care I was just like I love
that yeah I absolutely I love it I the
first time I saw it I saw it in 4dx
which have you ever been to one of those
things where the chairs
there was fans there was like water that
sprayed on me and I was like this is the
coolest thing ever
it was great I was literally like a kid
in a candy store because when the Jets
are like moving the chairs
you're like this is the next step closer
to being in the movie I'm so close
well hey let's talk about video games do
you because you work with Chief on G4
for a while so what what other video
games that have gone through your life
what are the important ones
um so I think the first couple would
probably be Sonic the Hedgehog Sega
Aladdin um
and the most iconic for me was Halo
because it was while I was living in New
York and I just this is the most
ridiculous story but it's when I was
gaming the most that I would order
Bagels from The Bagel Shop that was
literally downstairs from my apartment
right and one of the new Halo games had
come out and it was like the fourth or
fifth day that I'd ordered a bagel the
guy comes to the door and I open it and
I'm in the same clothes that I was in
from day one and he's like
are you okay I was like oh yeah I'm just
I've been playing a video game he was
like Oh Oh I thought you had a breakup
or you were sick or something like no
I'm enjoying myself I'm sorry that I'm
in the same clothes and you're
delivering me Bagels but I could just
walk downstairs but I'm not doing it oh
that's sweet they asked that we were we
were um asked that question a while ago
on the on the podcast have any of us uh
played Halo because I love the original
Halo I got really deep into that too
like the single I mean it's one of the
greatest multiplayer games ever the
original Halo but the single player game
with Master Chief I said to Billy
walking around kind of you know decrepit
broken down space stations and you think
oh it's kind of quiet nothing's going on
and then you turn the corner and all
those things
yeah you didn't show up you're like oh
God yeah yeah what a game yeah it
definitely it was one of those games
where I would play by myself and then
having the group play was so much fun
because I'm
I don't really like playing with other
people usually Halo's the only one that
I will right but if I want to play with
other people I want to play board games
like top person do you ever play League
of Legends I don't you should
I mean don't play it we're brilliant
I'm a bit better than him but he's true
every time you say stuff I'm like I
don't it's like I believe
yeah
what you're saying no we absolutely
absolutely absolutely do love to play it
I believe that you play I just don't
know that I believe that you're really
good at it yeah absolutely no he's good
um
but that's a fun game there's only five
people but they'll give you a hard time
yeah he just switches off the thing yeah
yeah but sometimes I like to read it
because it's hurtful but it it's a
learning you can learn experience when
someone says turn off this game and
never play it again yeah somebody said
please never play this game ever again
delete it from now I don't believe that
you're good at all no he is good he to
be honest he's improved yeah he is the
most improved player
yeah he went from being when we would
play we'd be like okay of course we
always want to play with Billy but be
like it's it's gonna be tough because
Billy is still at a point where he's
saying there's a lot of colors there's a
lot of noise there's a lot of activity
yeah I think I'm involved I'm not
entirely sure do you forget which
character you are sometimes sometimes
yeah sometimes I mean in the big battles
and everybody's I've just yeah I just
press all the buttons I'm supposed to
press and then I'll just let it happen
wait so I had a flashback when I was
telling you that I was Lord of the Rings
fan that would there was a reason I had
a question so did you guys always have
this dynamic or has this like developed
since doing the films well this is like
I feel like you no we're both heavily
medicated
um
I I took double today because I thought
you were gonna really get on my nerves
and you have been getting on my nerves I
got a stomach cramps
of just being in this space
um now we've always kind of we yeah we
we work together the closest out of
anyone I would think I mean obviously
Elijah and Sean did their thing but
there's also you know large sections of
the film where Sean's on his own oh I
just on his own
and they also have a kind of master
serve and dynamic which I think Pete was
very keen to kind of say to those guys
well certainly to Sean you're not equals
yeah you do call him Master Frodo he is
kind of your boss you do look up to him
but we're just mates I mean obviously
you know Aragon and borrow me become
mates yeah Legolas and gimley become
mates memory and Pippen are you know
related in in terms of their family tree
but they're just friends and I think
without Billy and I really talking about
too much I think we knew that we were
kind of one of the pure representations
of friendship and what we're ultimately
trying to save in that film and uh we're
both Brits so we kind of get that Pub
sense of humor and we're both medicated
so that that does help
yeah yeah as he just stares off into
space yeah as soon as we just started a
second as soon as we met it was like oh
because Dom was one of the last to
arrive on set so it was kind of worrying
because I thought I've got to spend a
lot of time with this guy I hope I like
him so we we did go out and played some
pool yeah and I had a couple of beers
the first night we met and uh we thought
oh yeah good this is going to be okay
because that's the worry isn't we've got
to work really closely with someone
whether it's a play or whatever you're
doing you're just thinking wow this is
going to be a long time but I also feel
like I don't know like I think there is
a natural
there is something that you either you
either have chemistry with someone or
you don't but as an actor I kind of feel
like that's part of our job is to make
people see that there if it even if it's
not yeah so like for Harry and Megan I
didn't meet who was playing Harry until
we were up there about to shoot right
and so I I went out of my way I was like
we're going to a hockey game together we
need to like spend time together to get
comfortable in each other's space but I
was like even if I don't like him which
we are really good friends like we zoom
over the pandemic gears and all that
kind of stuff but
um I was like we are gonna have the
chemistry that we need to have yeah but
I feel like that's part of our job I I
agree I think it is part of our job and
sometimes you have to mine for it a
little bit more than others I've
certainly done jobs where I've had to
you know kind of act like we are a lot
closer and and you know friendlier and
want to spend time with each other
because we play Partners or because we
play husband and wife the great thing
with Billy now was it was effortless and
also you know we just kind of chose to
spend time with each other like I said
when when they were shooting Helms Deep
and we were aware that we had a little
bit of uh a little bit more time than
normal we didn't just say all right see
you in a couple of weeks we were like
well let's go learn to scuba dive at the
weekend we'd be surfing we'd always be
hanging out with each other
um it's that yes and thing right yeah
which I didn't I was never really
exposed to the yes and thing of course I
was improvising in you know Workshop
stuff when I was a kid in plays and
stuff but no one in Manchester or in
England said to me is this yes and thing
where when you get to the end of
something you want your partner to say
great yes and we build on that and then
and then you keep it in the air yeah
billionaire just seemed to instinctually
know that with each other so you always
know that it's never gonna fall flat
because is the other person's gonna pick
it up for you yeah which helps when
you're on stage I mean Billy and I have
done a few conventions this year and we
do these panels on stage and you know
sometimes things can be a little bit
clunky the question isn't gray or maybe
you've answered that question 20 times
before and we can all kind of tell if
someone is slightly struggling and
you're very quick to kind of yes end and
help them out you know yeah yeah Billy
and Dom eat the world
are you gonna be able to eat anything
I'm gonna do it you I mean you should be
happy because mine's pretty bland will
you thank me do you would you like a
ghost pepper with yours
why not all right great just a bag we'll
show you how much I'm not gonna eat the
seed though no don't you sure you won't
do that William don't talk her out of an
experience well I wouldn't Don what are
you gonna do with this pepper because do
you think no I'm going to taste a piece
of the pepper after everything I'm not
doing it now it's always a good job we
still have some of these what was it
called Dom Carolina Reaper but I I
unfortunately called it the calorina
reaper he couldn't get it out for a few
times you could almost not get there the
Carolina Reaper it was good the great
thing I would say about it is it is hot
and spicy but the feeling lasts for
about 10 minutes let's go you'll you'll
notice if you eat it down in the seed
which I did I don't think he did then
it's much more intimidated don't worry
unless you want it really intense I
could have eaten the seeds and run a
mile John ate the seeds and he had to
run to the nearest toilet
rolling a potato which is my father's
favorite meal hello Dad why a potato I'm
like not the biggest Foodie in the world
but a baked potato with cheddar cheese
and bacon and butter and sour cream is
like the most comfort food of comfort
foods for me I'm gonna I'm gonna taste
it it was making by Johnny clue yeah do
you remember it was was potatoes a big
thing in your family
I thought you were about to look in the
bio if it's anything about potatoes I've
got the wrong bird
um I don't like
no
question really picky when I was I'm
trying to think because I don't remember
a lot of stuff from when I was younger
but I think it's because they're all
such good memories so it's like
everything kind of Blends together so
sometimes I'm like did I do that did I
like this the Whirlwind yeah like I know
I liked pasta with just a lot of butter
and cheese that's all I would eat was it
was your parents did they cook a lot of
stuff yeah my mom's a really good cook
my dad would cook too he had like
specific things he would do breakfast
for dinner so it was really exciting
when Dad would cook because he would do
that at night I love breakfast for
dinner scrambled eggs and pancakes for
dinner time you wouldn't eat it though
because someone else made it for you oh
yeah
how good are my scrambled eggs Billy the
scrambled eggs are actually very good do
you know what though it concerns me yes
that you won't eat other people's food
now do I want to eat what you make
exactly a lot of Johnny Clues made this
I didn't make this but yeah I do
struggle with other people's uh food
sometimes but my scrambled eggs come
directly out of the Waldorf Hotel in
London which is also Gordon Ramsay's uh
restaurant and so it's basically Gordon
Ramsay's method
it's not even a different it's not it's
not I was like wait do you ship the eggs
from England no I just follow his method
there's no there's nothing different
about the eggs or what he puts in the
eggs he just has a completely different
method for making them than what we used
to do you put milk in them it makes them
slow that's his big this is the thing
yeah slow and stirred we gotta get a lot
of air in there and you gotta keep it
cool so as soon as it starts to turn
into what you think is scrambled eggs
what you take it off the heat take it
off the activity and then you let it
cool down and then you put a little bit
of heat and then if it gets yeah I don't
want the patience for that yeah so the
scrambled eggs will take like 20 minutes
but my God no no oh the delicious
very good incredible but this potato is
very good and I was very hungry John
Johnny Clues you made this in a real
oven didn't you a real oven you've done
well I like to do uh you cover an olive
oil some salt pepper I usually do garlic
salt but um not this week unfortunately
and then about 90 minutes
oh yeah yep I poke holes on every side
well all around 360 Degrees see this is
the thing I was saying I don't like to
cook very much so when they were like
tell us a food that you really enjoy
yeah usually when I get a baked potato I
order it from somewhere and they do you
really is that not a stranger when you
order it do they go a lot of places that
have steaks and stuff they always have
like a baked potato on the side and so
I'll just get a baked potato and like a
salad or my favorite is at Bob's Big Boy
they have baked potatoes and then I'll
also get a black and white milkshake and
that's like so what is that coffee and
vanilla no it's vanilla ice cream with
chocolate syrup I don't love chocolate
ice cream so I like having the vanilla
and the chocolate together do you have a
very very strict stringent um gym
routine because why are you not six
thousand pounds I do work out a lot but
I also don't do this all the time like I
really do think there is
when you work out and you do it often
enough you can have days where you eat a
baked potato and have a milkshake
absolutely you can well don't if you're
aware enjoy it but Billy Boyd sat to my
left here hello hello he's currently
bulking dude I'm both gonna tell Tiffany
about you bulking I'm basically eating a
lot and I'm left in huge weights
how much are you lifting now
like for a deadlift
for a deadlift I've got my knee okay
excuse me wait now I feel like you don't
lift it all you just looked at him to
say
give me a yes and give me a yes then I
like eating a lot I know I thought
I'll just call it Balkan yeah and I'll
see how big I can get
so wait are you not lifting weights
but I'm probably not eating I'm eating
more than I'm left
he wants to get did you watch Game of
Thrones yes do you remember the mountain
he's hoping to kind of get
we were saying the other day so big that
if he was walking down a High Street
for a mini Mountain they'd either think
it was the mountain all people would
start to you know like move out the way
from distance you'd be like oh my God
look at him get out of the way get out
the way he wants that type of side and I
think you can achieve it I'm gonna keep
trying I think beet potatoes will
probably help that it's true so I never
really lifted weights and then during
the pandemic I started training at a gym
and doing a lot of weightlifting and my
body has never changed as quickly as it
did weightlifting it should be forwarded
I've got a friend back home who's a
trainer and has been for years
and he's always said that's that's the
big that's the big difference you know
don't don't do a ton of cardio you know
do cardio it's good for your heart it's
good for your lungs and all that but
don't don't try and change your body or
anything
lift weights which is what I do good job
there was a plate there otherwise you
would have a mashed potato crotch so
there's nothing worse done nothing worse
right potatoes are so good man these are
very good John this is a great time with
the two of you guys but now just like
leveled up even more yeah no it's
fantastic we've not spoke about anything
about the potato one of the most iconic
vegetables on the planet because I don't
have my bio anymore I think I might have
eaten it in a fit of Joy but do you
could you say just something about the
potato would you like to know something
about the biggest civilization there's a
history about it oh my God here we go
he's kept civilizations alive for
centuries William This is Gonna Make Me
Feel let's let's I'll do it as a
question and answer very cool
um and the annual fruit crop of the
world
[Music]
where do you think potatoes you know
rice potatoes now that's in terms of how
much is farmed where where yeah or how
much the volume oh the volume of it I'm
gonna say number one number one in the
world of food Farms
what would you say biggest way I mean
what way is heavier than a potato no no
this is based off of weight or this is
baked well that's why you explained that
William no but that's the amount oh yeah
how is I need more details
you're being vague be more clear the
annual crop yes wait wait I'm gonna say
number one I'm going to say it's the
heaviest I'm going to say maybe the
heaviest individually no I mean I'm
gonna say number three
Tiffany's much closer or is it seven
it's four it's four what's number one
rice sweet rice
uh I don't know about order to go ahead
but rice wheat and corn oh of course
come on when do you think it was first
cultivated this is good doing it as a
question and answer I'll give you I'll
give you give us some options
I get the hate trivia
Tiffany we're gonna fall out I get no
here's what will happen we do trivia and
I let you answer everything because I
get really stressed out if I don't know
because you're you're answering first if
I don't want to put on YouTube I'll sit
at home and put on a general trivia quiz
and just see what I can answer correctly
yeah I love trivia me who was the first
man to Moon and Neil Armstrong that guy
who played the trumpet
um what give me can I have multiple
choice but
right when was it first cultivated I'll
give you an I'll give you a clue it was
first cultivated by the Inca
now was that around
eight thousand five thousand BC five
thousand two thousand BC or two thousand
to one thousand BC that's 85. you're not
a nice trivia man
you could have done like one that was
like
two thousand uh 1945 yeah right okay was
it eight thousand five thousand BC five
thousand two thousand BC
on 1945.
just after the war when was the first
potatoes
B well you're wrong because it was a
yeah eight thousand five thousand BC
I'll give you one dumb you ready and go
and give us one so it was first
cultivated eight to five thousand BC
correct correct did it get to Europe
1000 BC
BC
180. you have the paper in front of me I
know or 1 500 A.D I'm gonna say one
thousand five hundred yeah you're right
I'm out of the Spanish conquistadors
Concord Peru this isn't a competition
between the two of us it is a little bit
usually my entire life is a competition
between me and other people sorry I'm
very competitive sorry but we definitely
should play Magic yeah let's play Magic
why don't you guys go and play it yeah
we should I think one of my favorite
Spanish words is conquistetto which you
just said Billy do you speak a little
Spanish Tiffany
espanol but I Japan
oh a little bit of French love it is is
that based on your upbringing did you
study at school
enjoy your potato enjoy your potato
hey William Tell us some more he put
potato in his mouth and he's gonna start
talking to you yeah I'll tell you the
listeners hate that like a little
hamster dude I really hate that yeah
we did the thing we did uh we did a show
of hands show of hands and uh people
said they didn't like it yeah we would
we were consistently chewing on the mic
because we were like like I'm doing
right now yeah and they were like
absolutely delicious I love that right
United States and the baked potato yeah
although earlier Americans enjoyed baked
potatoes similar to their English
counterparts the more modern version
came in large part due to the efforts of
the Northern Pacific railroad in the
early 20th century the company's Dining
Car superintendent his and Titus became
is that his last name Mr Hazen Titus
well it may be pronounced sounds like
something I have a fairy tale t-i-t did
you get this off
this is all made for us by Johnny Johnny
did you get it from Wikipedia yeah
yeah it's the Hazen Titus became
enamored with the enormous Idaho Potato
yeah
often weeing
between two and five pounds
you could have given us that as an
option yeah you put a quiz yeah okay I
would never have guessed five pounds
they were widely considered unwieldy for
traditional cooking and thus fed to
Hogs Hogs and particular Hogs yes yeah
meanwhile however his and Titus found
them to be delicious
when he begged them for a long time yeah
but I don't know five or six hours for
those guys it began to promote them and
incorporate them in the menus of the
Northern Pacific railroad you basically
started doing commercials for potatoes
a five pound potato I mean I just did a
commercial for potatoes bringing I was
like guys let's eat potatoes yeah we
love potatoes we got Idaho Potato I
would say is the most famous potato from
the United States right I mean
okay are you making their is there a
competition between types of potatoes
yeah
they're like baby potatoes red potatoes
and potatoes Idaho potatoes I like the
fingerlings oh there's another one
fingerlings
food fuds and new Delectables will come
and go
however the potatoes are to stay it's
have you read this yeah it's a safe bet
that the potato and specifically the
baked potatoes here is stay and it will
remain as popular in the future as it
has done
for hundreds of years
now Tiffany you will
in a perfect world have a baked potato
with cheese bacon and butter is that
your all-time favorite way to have a
baked potato yeah with sour cream and
ranch dressing on the side oh wow
um
I think
butter salt and pepper
I like I like it hot I put some hot
sauce in there maybe a little cayenne
pepper a little turmeric something like
that what about your bills I'd have it
with tuna fish
mayonnaise
and a a finely sliced onion see again
you're doing the thing where you're
looking right at me and I'm like
it's true
not mayonnaise yeah and then it's my
wife who says you should cut up an onion
I love raw red onions give us a crunch
no he said hot pepper Tiffany wait what
about sweet corn no sweet corn in that
paper towel that's a great combination
with tuna and mayonnaise I know you mean
John but I just I'm trying to make it
easy for myself and I don't know if I've
got sweet corn
if I'm bulking
I might not even bother with the onion
yeah should we move on no we get their
scores
but before we score it do you really
want to taste that I do actually I think
you really think because I'm saying you
shouldn't I'm doing it well like how
much I I need to know like how much like
we did like did you eat this whole thing
no no no like this little nuts no no no
no see that's two different hold on I'll
point out with the legs of your glasses
Billy so see this top bit it's got no
heat it's like a bell pepper you get a
taste from there but see that little bit
that looks like a little swirly doodad
like that bite that I'd have something
maybe the size of a half a penny or a
quarter of a penny something like that
but try try the little spiky bit because
they'll be it'll just be like a bell
pepper initially there'll be nothing
that you'll think oh that's hot it's
just like a bell pepper right
foreign
that's all right you'll be okay with
that I think
it was a swirl s you never even took it
come on just like like this like a
quarter of a penny come on I can't I
can't eat a quarter of a penny my mouth
is already
an eighth of a penny I took it down the
seed Stone didn't even know if you did
get to the seeds you know oh no that's
too much is it
but don't touch it don't touch your eyes
yeah don't touch your eyes now talk us
through your symptoms
um heat to hot heat so first my tongue
was really hot now my whole throat is
really okay right don't touch your eyes
I know don't don't use that because
that's been on there I actually got hot
teeth hot teeth and hot dogs yeah I got
the heckling this is really hot it's hot
isn't it fine no you're doing okay great
we're going to give scores to the baked
potato okay oh my gosh the first thing
we do
yeah the first thing we do the potato
will help yeah because it it'll nullify
didn't he said don't eat up any root
vegetable he said she always activate it
can I have what can I have a tissue for
My Eyes Crying oh okay don't touch it
you touch the paper with this thing use
the other one now here's the bottom one
you're fine oh
Tiffany what does it feel like
you're like your cute little face is
perspiring it feels like I got something
in my eye like yeah touch your eyes
whatever you do no flavor potatoes
there's no flavor no no no
that's the first thing that we score and
also just so you know one of the first
symptoms of eating hot pepper is
absolute Madness and it does seem like
you're moving into that Arena all crying
yeah Billy let's you and I do a flavor
thing and give Tiffany a moment just to
collect herself the flavor of a baked
potato especially when made by Johnny
Cruz is up there as one of the greatest
flavors available to the humankind I
disagree why well I would say a baked
potato that doesn't include any of the
gobbins the effects like same chicken
soup is just what
yeah so we're including the stuff that
you add into it yeah is that what we're
saying yeah in that case yeah it's quite
good right potatoes are those potatoes
are good they're like the best thing in
the world
potatoes are good I just found them a
little boring but yeah if you had some
fixings and I did add some hot sauce all
right I'm giving it a six out of ten I'm
giving a 9.1 wow I like it I love the
flavor Tiffany
about that potato experience crying
because of how much you don't like
potatoes I'm sorry I like it Mom do you
want to score it as well I mean
yeah I mean in general the score of
baked potatoes I would say 10 out of ten
I'll wait 10 out of 10 out of 10. this
baked potato I like the cheese to be
really melty
God's sake man
like a 9.9 well that's all right he went
and got up he went out and got all the
stuff and he made the bacon crispy which
is like point one of the decimal point
they were made three hours ago
sweet Jesus how are you feeling though
wait no you guys was running wait till
you get the stomach crumbs I'm not gonna
get the stomach cramps
that's because I went down to received
snobdales went down
really uh
the Aesthetics of a baked potato which
to be fair I would say looks like a
rhino [ __ ] what
what I like to do well it's not when
it's not being cooked yeah yeah I cut it
I cut it and then I'll open it like a
flower remember those toys used to get
when you were younger one two three four
five six color blue what b
u e
pick a number three one two three right
pick one of them right who is this who
I'm gonna marry yeah you love Jane ah
who's Jane I'm still married to Allison
who is Jay I'm not saying Eugene sorry
Alison holy moly oh you're okay
I keep thinking I'm okay and then my
mouth is like no you're not wait dude no
I'm afraid to breathe in I think it will
make it hotter no yeah just breathe out
wait till the cramps come did you go
downstairs I'm the only one who went
down
yeah
the the look The Aesthetics of a baked
potato with the fixings or without the
fixings I see we've got to go with
though
cheddar cheese
Salt and Pepper please sure it comes for
that
oh philistine
uh I mean it's a nice look it's a nice
look I don't eat bacon but it's a nice
look I'm gonna give it an eight yeah I
like it I'm gonna give it an 8.4
so you think it looks Less Pleasant than
it tastes yeah
um I mean it's not like you know if you
went a Japanese restaurant
you like like okay you like presentation
food well I'm just saying
I like I see food like that and I'm like
that's not food is it I'm gonna make it
messy and then I feel bad eating it uh
so that's what that's the reason why you
define yourself as not a foodie for you
food is functional it has to make you
feel good and fill up your tummy yeah
and you're like enough with all the fat
I don't want plants and flowers on my
plate I like plants and flowers on my
plate but I like
if it's like a baby bite I'm like no but
I'm hungry I'm sitting down because I
want a meal what about a king bite do
you ever create a king bite for yourself
what's that King Bay is like you have
created what you consider to be the Best
Buy in your meal where you're like I've
tried this sauce I've tried this side
thing I know it's hard what happened to
you guys where it's like randomly all of
your saliva and then you swallow it and
your saliva is really hot yeah have you
got a post map back in my neck no it's
just like right it's just like all in my
mouth my thing is because I took it down
to the seeds I don't think you did it
did you eat the seeds yeah
my ears were sweating that's the years
were sweating yeah takes a lot it's like
an elephant
um
uh wait we were talking about potatoes
presentations
yeah the way that you ever came back is
you've tried all the things right and
you're like right well I don't want too
much of the gravy because it's okay but
it's not great so you create a king bite
and then you have that when you're at
your most hungry so I do like a weird
thing because I think
I used to everything always had to be
separated for me when I was little um so
I can't decide sometimes if I want to
have the best bite first when I'm hungry
to enjoy it yeah or save it to the end
but then I'm full so I don't enjoy it as
much I think you have a star my friends
used to me and my friend Tom used to
always threaten it never happened to go
to McDonald's and eat the whole menu
never happened yeah I could have done it
but Tom always claimed that he could do
it and I always used to debate with him
I was like well what would we have first
and he was like get the rubbish out of
the way yeah have the hamburger the
cheeseburger the nuggets and I was like
no no have the best thing first because
you want to celebrate the meal and then
you just sluggishly get through and then
at the end you won't enjoy it never
happened before you won't enjoy it okay
perfect bait that was a king bite uh
Barbra Streisand did that in a movie
Once I think it was Oriental no I think
it was um funny girl uh he's a funny
girl no what's up doc not sure is it the
hot sauce Maybe
this hot pepper it's yeah sometimes I
just zone out I was like am I supposed
to just put my thumb in my mouth is that
what this is for yeah apparently uh
Jordan says yeah whipped cream is
supposed to work anyway I've given my
score for the Aesthetics right we all
have oh so now I give it I gave it a 9.9
yeah 9.9 because yeah usefulness Billy
this is a category that Billy ten
talk us through the different ways that
it can be used oh usefulness for my body
or like potatoes if you want to talk
about your body that's fine but let's
use it if a light bulb breaks you can
use a potato no no there's no light
coming out of a potato I've tried it
I've turned off all the lights at night
screw it if your light bulb breaks you
shove the potato onto it and you unscrew
it that might be extremely enough if you
plug a light bulb in your potato it will
later up because it works as a battery
yeah there's some electricity
you can make french fries you can make
hash browns from a baked potatoes uh but
we're just talking that's a potato
you're taking it back so usefulness I
use our baked potato
if you're in the house
um and there's a baked potato maybe from
the day before and you're like oh I've
got guests coming over I've got baked
potato I've got three eggs I've got a
quarter milk an orange orange I've got
eight what can I do ice cubes do I have
my telephone
people downstairs to give you a bagel
you've got to make something from that
is it useful can I do something
versatile I mean I could probably make
some kind of a like shepherd's pie
something or other
with nice oil yeah make it crispy yeah
sounding pretty useful to me don't
swim also like yeah always goes loose
for you that much I know maybe if you're
struggling
oh do you yeah if you've lost if you've
lost the baseball at a game could you
potentially use that no no just a one
hit baseball no no
Cat round campfires very good to have a
baked potato oh yeah right the best
baked potato ever had I'll take you back
a bit here Tiffany back back back many
years
a guy tried to blow up the houses of
Parliament in Britain
his name was Guy Fawkes
and they they he didn't do it but
from that day on on Guy Fawkes Day all
the kids get together and build big
fires and they put Guy Fawkes on it yeah
but on Guy Fawkes Night we're at where I
came from we would also get potatoes and
wrap them in tin foil and throw it at
the bottom of the fire and then hours
later when the fires went down you would
get your potato out and put butter on it
and that was a that was the best meal
you'd ever have I like that yeah
and a little bit of British history
I'm doing a lot of history yeah yeah can
we do a history corner on the show yeah
is there any particular period in
history that you want to learn about
because Billy's quite a buff
what's what's the blind spot for you in
history I mean it could be innocent
innocent I don't know I'm like what
would I want to know about it exactly I
mean the Russian Revolution I like want
to know all about like BC stuff like way
back
yeah I'll do something for you next week
definitely right so usefulness
usefulness I'm going to have this I'm
giving it a high one I'm giving a
8.7
I was good I've been swayed by the two
of you because initially I was like well
it's just a baked potato there's not a
lot going on there but I actually think
you guys are persuaded me so I'm gonna
go high then I thought
8.3 well that's quite High actually I
mean
potatoes getting up there you're
obsessed I love them I also just had a
thought I was like I wonder if they put
hot pepper stuff into like lip balms
that are supposed to like puff your lips
up oh yeah yeah it feels like that now
how is it where is it now where now it's
just at the back of my lips and the rest
is pretty much gone what about yourself
palette I had it in a soft palate for a
long time it's on like the back of my
tongue a little bit still yeah it tends
to go after around about 10 minutes yeah
I think you're good do you want another
bite no I don't right I'm good I don't
have any stomach cramps my eyes have
stopped watering you probably won't get
the cramps because you didn't go down to
the seeds
um well did you a score for uh no you
didn't usefulness yeah I said 9.9
offered wow
you've gone you've gone ten nine point
nine nine point nine yeah that sounds
like you with my mate have you tried
marmite
do you even know like brown stuff yeah
in a jar it's like a brown yeast section
he loves the extracts it's like
it's Savory Savory very quite Umami do
you like Umami stuff
I don't like mushrooms I don't like
olives I like pickles we love mushrooms
I mean I like truffle oil but I don't I
have a texture texture is my thing with
food if I don't like the texture of
something I'm like no I'm good you have
to be careful about eating too many
mushrooms though don't you because it
turns you into a fungi to be with
does it make you tell jokes like that
dad jokes sometimes I'm here for the dad
jokes hey bills we've run out of time I
know well it's been wonderful having you
on it's been wonderful just delving a
little deeper into the world of the
potato hasn't it yep who knew thank you
and thanks for um playing long and
eating a pepper because I think most
guests would say I'm good yeah I like
that why not you you are positive and I
like it I like your Vibe me too I hope
there's a lot of great things in the
future I really do well thanks coming on
the show Tiffany thank you for having me
and bringing potatoes we've run out of
time we'll see you guys next week make
sure you rate review And subscribe to
the show every time I see you
I love you and I love potatoes
[Music]
see you next week guys on the Friendship
onion toodles bye-bye
[Music]
harmonize with
[Music]
Meister baby you're my Pearl